[Music]
foreign
here in this video we will showcase the
10 biggest movie demons no we do not
worship them anyway demons have always
been the most dreaded monsters in all of
cultures and myths right there alongside
dragons and guide you and the same goes
for movies so let's get to that list
at number 10 we have the balrog from The
Fellowship of the Ring during Spain also
known as the Battle of Moria is a
powerful and ancient creature originally
the battle Rock was one of the Maya
spirits who served Margot the first dark
lord of Middle Earth when morgoth was
defeated in the first age some of his
followers including the balrogs fled to
hiding the battle Rock and morya
remained dormant for thousands of years
until the dwarves of kazadum
accidentally Disturbed his Slumber and
then deduct too deep for mithril a
precious metal then awoken him from his
long sleeve endurance Bane emerged as a
fiery demonic creature shrouded in
Shadow and Wheeling a whip of flame and
a sword
number nine the puzzle Guardian the
puzzle Guardians are characters in The
Hellraiser film series and Comics they
are filthy looking vagrants who serve as
the Protectors of the lament
configuration puzzle box in the comics
it is revealed that there is a puzzle
Guardian for every puzzle to hell they
are created by the cinnabite owner who
Alters the mind of denizens of hell and
impregnates a woman with their seat the
woman that dies during childbirth and
when the child reaches 16 of age honor
reveals their Destiny as deposit
guardian and gives them the puzzle they
will guard
number 8 the demon bear seen in the New
Mutants the demon bear is an entity
associated with the character called
Dany Moonstar it is a physical
manifestation of her greatest fear and
possesses several formidable abilities
these include superhuman strength
demonstrated by its ability to send
people flying and defeat buffle
characters like Sunspot it exhibits Nai
invulnerability as its tough skin makes
it highly resistant to attacks it can
heal itself over time displaying a
regenerative ability additionally it
possesses teleportation Powers allowing
it to move between locations it is
fueled by negative emotions and becomes
stronger when others fight against it
particularly in fear
number seven death Ghidorah Des guitar
is a demonic three-headed dragon kaijuda
first appeared in a 1996 film The
Rebirth of Mothra he is an evil space
monster who caused Devastation on Mars
before turning his attention to Earth
the giant moth Guardians known as Mothra
and Mothra Leo managed to defeat and
seal him away but he was awakened to the
present day does guitar attempted to
destroy all life on Earth again but was
confronted by Mothra and her son Mothra
Leo after a fierce battle Mothra
sacrificed herself and Leo ultimately
defeated death Ghidorah sealing him away
for good
number 6 maligor coming from the Power
Rangers franchise maligo known as the
great flame of Destruction is an ancient
all-powerful lava demon he was
imprisoned by the ancestors of an
ancient wizard an alien wizard called
Larry God the main antagonist sought to
resurrect malago and marry him to gain
control over the universe malgo
possesses immense strength making him
one of the strongest enemies of the
Power Rangers and he easily overpowered
all five of them and defeated the turbo
Megazord one of malaga's unique
abilities is self-enlargement unlike
other monsters in the turbo series
madago can make himself grow by causing
Flames to explode from within him
number five the tower bridge demon the
demon served as supporting antagonists
in the 2019 American Supernatural
superhero movie called Hellboy some of
the Demons were quickly seen in a vision
in which Hellboy would lead them to
destroy Humanity while riding on a large
dragon-like Beast the demons were
released from hell when Hellboy pulled
Excalibur from an ancient stone there
were several types of demons that went
Rampage all over the world but the
biggest that was seen was the one that
destroyed the tower bridge in London
standing taller than the structure
number four Satan in the movie called
This is the End Lucifer also known as
Satan or the devil is the main
antagonist his primary goal is to bring
about Armageddon and destroy all life on
Earth he seeks to increase his number of
doomed Souls under his control he
unleashes his hellish Legions to possess
humans manipulating them to do his
bidding and causing widespread chaos and
death he appears as a humanoid demon
with hoof legs horns and multiple
eagle-like heads protruding from his
back his towering feet can easily
demolish buildings and structures with a
mere Stomp
number three is serger in the MCU certa
is a gigantic fire demon who hails from
an extra dimensional realm known as
muspelheim he is depicted as a towering
figure with a flaming crown and a
massive flaming sword called Twilight
which possesses the power to bring about
the prophesied event called Ragnarok the
destruction of Asgard as the rule of
muspelheim he can generate and control
Flames soda's Final Act is to thrust his
flaming sword into asgard's foundations
causing a cataclysmic explosion that
completely annihilates the realm
number 2 dormammu seen in the MCU as the
main antagonist of the first Doctor
Strange movie dormammu is an ancient and
Incredibly powerful demonic being from
the dark dimension a realm outside the
conventional space-time of the Marvel's
Universe he is depicted as a massive
flame-headed entity which were magical
Flames not like fire he also had an
immense power and a hunger for Conquest
he possesses Godlike abilities including
energy manipulation teleportation and
the ability to manipulate reality itself
here's a glutton for consuming other
universes into his own and also for
manipulating lesser models
and number one Apophis in the movie gods
of Egypt the Demonic God called Apophis
is a primordial beast known as the 10th
region of the night dwelling in the
realm of Shadow he is driven by a desire
to consume all of creation a puff is
born from Ra's appearance or Essence
emerges from the sea of chaos as an
embodiment of entropy every night it
attempts to kill ra while the God Ra
fights him and drives him back drives
him away from consuming the Earth
Apophis has the appearance of a gigantic
worm glad and Shadow and smoke his size
is indeterminate but definitely the
biggest on this list
so those are the 10 biggest movie demons
anyway I hope you have enjoyed watching
this video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
on new videos here on this channel take
care fam